Assassin's Creed has made substantial
changes to its gameplay since the first
game park called into our lives some 13
years ago so with the reveal of the
latest title Assassin's Creed Valhalla
let's take a look at how the series has
evolved and the big additions each main
line entry has brought to the table
sorry handhelds let's take it back to
where it all began 2007 Assassin's Creed
which had three core pillars social
stealth platforming and combat and
obviously assassinating targets but I'd
argue that that falls under all of the
above back then stealth played a huge
role in the game and they really leaned
in to you being a knife or should I say
hidden blade in the dark he could sneak
around blending in with crowds to lose
heat and enemies had an awareness
indicator
you also had a rudimentary version of
Eagle vision that helps you locate
targets and hiding spots unfortunately
it also limited your movement which was
not ideal when another core part of the
game was its movement AC took us out
into an open world and led us free run
all over it
scaling towers synchronizing viewpoints
and of course leaping into hay bales to
get back down again Assassin's Creed
referred to it stealth as low-profile
actions and there was a designated
button to make you go high-profile these
high-profile activities included its
beloved parkour as well as open combat
admittedly enemies would usually only
attack you one at a time so it wasn't
ever really that difficult Assassin's
Creed laid a strong foundation and its
sequel built on it with a load of new
additional systems like economics you
can invest money in renovating your
villa which would then grant new income
as well as discounts and shops this
feature would then be expanded into
citywide renovation in later games
stealth changed too and then when our
multiple new ways to take out enemies
like using smoke bombs to clear
line-of-sight or hiring bands of thieves
or courtesans to blend in with there was
also a new notoriety system take too
much heat and your face would be
recognizable
you'd have to tear down posters or bribe
heralds otherwise guards would recognize
you and attack on-site you can now use
eagle vision while moving which was
genuinely huge combat changed too with
new enemy types and moves
as well as new weapons and upgrades made
available through the lovable Leonardo
da Vinci who also provided you with a
flying machine because of course he did
parkour didn't change that much but you
could leap while climbing now to get
some extra momentum and Ezio could even
swim
these parkour abilities would come into
their own during the assassin tomb
segments parkour puzzles that would
reward Ezio with Altai ears Armour set
if they were all completed brotherhood
added a slew of smaller things like dual
wielding more weapon options including
heavy weapons ranged combat options and
a horse you could call at any time but
it's two major contributions were
apprentices and multiplayer you could
recruit NPCs to your cause and level
them up by giving them contracts and
even call on them in battle but
multiplayer was the biggest addition
you'd spend matches trying to identify
other real players hiding among the many
NPCs while simultaneously trying to
remain unnoticed to take out your
enemies quickly and quietly super
intense but a whole lot of fun and
something that was genuinely really
different while multiplayer would stick
around in the series for a while the
tower defense sequences from Revelations
would not it was a minigame added to
ensure that you kept the city of
Constantinople under assassin rule by
fighting off waves of Templars but it
felt very out of place in an assassin's
Creed game a new addition to parkour was
the hook blade which made zipping around
the city a breeze and acted like a
front-runner of sorts for the rope
launcher that we would use in syndicate
revelations was big on bomb crafting
which was fine if a little unnecessary
the game's core combat still wasn't very
difficult with your expanded armory and
the fact that you could chain kills
easily meant that it was never ever
really that challenging with the Ezio
trilogy over it was time to go to the
frontier as well as cities Boston and
New York parkouring became easier as the
control scheme changed and the new
assassin Connor could clamber up and
down and between trees as well as around
rooftops with ease combat had a huge
overhaul feeling more like Batman Arkham
countering with context-specific
actions like using an enemy as a shield
it still never became that challenging
though especially as the game removed
healing items and let Conor's Health
just regenerate outside of combat
instead a new co-op mode called Wolfpack
was added which saw up to four players
group up to assassinate NPCs whether
impacted your movement and visibility
and there was hunting now two three was
also the first to feature naval combat
Connor had his own warship and you could
fire cannons and board enemy ships
however this only really took place
during side missions but in the next
game would be spending a whole lot more
time at sea speaking of spending time at
sea you'd spend about 40% of Black Flag
at sea like in three side missions you
take on other ships firing your cannons
and ramming enemy vessels but you could
also Scout ships ahead of time with your
trusty spyglass to see what booty was on
offer in an evolution of recruiting
apprentices you could board ships and
recruit the defeated enemies to your
crew naturally for a game about pirates
there was a lot of sunken treasure that
you could die for and I'll go on record
here the underwater levels were actually
decent
you can also free aim with your pistols
making long-range weapons way more
viable we haven't talked about playing
as Desmond the hapless bartender at the
heart of the modern day segments but
that's because he didn't really do that
much in Black Flag though we stopped
playing as him completely
instead switching to a first-person
perspective of a newbie at Abstergo
industries poor rogue caught a bit left
behind releasing at the same time as
Assassin's Creed unity but only for
previous gen consoles while unity got to
be on the new shiny next gen for better
or for worse rogue had naval combat but
you can now Ram icebergs in the North
Atlantic and release oil slicks and set
them on fire enemies could now also
board your ship and as a Templar
protagonist che had different weapons
including an air rifle which also had a
grenade launcher attachment for some
reason it also had way more
environmental hazards like gas barrels
that could send you berserk unless you
managed to put on a mask in time the AC
game worlds had been getting bigger and
bigger but I don't think anyone was
ready for a one-to-one rendering of some
of Paris's landmarks like Notre Dame in
order to clamber around these landmarks
more fish
le the freerunning controls changed
again this time with a specific button
to allow you to climb up and another to
climb down although it wasn't really
that popular among fans they did
introduce skill trees to the franchise
and tried something cool with
assassinations calling them black box
missions basically the game would show
you your target and it'll be up to you
to choose how you'd get the kill making
you feel more like an actual assassin
adapting to the situation rather than
you just following a bunch of prompts
building on from Wolf Pack mode it also
introduced co-op for up to four players
in campaign missions but lost the
competitive multiplayer entirely
syndicate gave us not one but two
assassins two players each with their
own distinct style the brawler Jacob and
the stealthier Evie London was even
bigger than Paris and so to get around
easier
the twins had a rope launcher at their
disposal to help them zip about but with
the side effect that it took any kind of
challenge or deliberateness out of the
park or the London boroughs under
Templar control needed to be liberated
by first undermining the rulers by
undertaking various activities when they
were sufficiently weakened you could
initiate a full-on gang war and claim
the turf for your own they also dropped
the coop for syndicate taking Assassin's
Creed back to its fully
single-player routes Assassin's Creed
origins was massive to help navigate it
a little easier the game ditched the
mini-map instead opting for a compass
bar on screen eagle vision turned into a
literal eagle with sin you who you could
use to scout out and mark enemies
through the game's extensive skill tree
you could even upgrade her to attack
enemies for you
setting obviously can't go inside so it
introduced a pulse type thing to help
you scan for items indoors and the skill
tree wasn't the only RPG mechanic that
was added there was a full crafting
system in place to combat changed to be
a hitbox based system and as many at the
time pointed out it played a little bit
like Dark Souls especially because byuk
had a rutti shield by it could build up
energy in his adrenaline gauge and
unleash a furious finisher or enter a
state where he's faster and stronger
which was useful because they were more
intricate boss fights against mythical
godlike creatures
there wasn't any sort of traditional
multiplayer or co-op in origins but
there was some online interactivity you
could see pictures that other players
had taken or find the body of others and
take on revenge missions
if origins was dipping the franchise's
toes into RPG territory
Odyssey was the cannonball into the pool
you could choose between two
protagonists Alexios and Cassandra
there was decision-making branching
questlines romance options multiple
endings skill trees the lot but perhaps
the biggest addition was a shadow of
Mordor esque nemesis system where if you
started to gain notoriety mercenaries
would track you down and try and take
you out each merc had their own
backstory strengths and weaknesses and
by taking them out you'd gain notoriety
and rise through the ranks we should
offer you bonuses in the rest of the
world like increased rewards or shop
discounts and if you felt like odyssey
had a little too much going on on-screen
and you're just following a dotted line
from one mission to the next its
exploration mode stripped all that out
forcing you to actually talk to your
NPCs and learn about your surroundings
to figure out where to go next
and now we're at the Viking Age with AC
Valhalla there's a couple of things we
can glean from the reveal CGI trailer
such as The Raven which will likely be
our eagle vision eye in the sky the
hidden blade of course makes a dramatic
appearance and given that the Vikings
were known for their long ships we can
pretty much guarantee a return to see
players take control of either a Viking
radar turned leader that's trying to
find a new home for his people in
England as part of that we'll be able to
conduct raids grow settlements and build
palette influence to earn a place among
the gods how does that shake out in
gameplay well we're not quite sure yet
but we'll have more in the coming weeks
about Valhalla zookeeper GameSpot
[Music]
you